oh hey didn't hear you come in I don't
know why I decided to do some weird
cheesy opening like it's a special
episode of a kids program or something
hey everybody how you doing
couldn't straighten them frigging thing
out so it's gonna be tilted the other
way this time
ain't that fun hope everyone's having a
decent week if you're in the States
presumably you have Thursday off of work
so there's that you're late oh for God's
sakes
if 15 seconds at most come on now ah was
there a new video today kind of I did an
update of my patreon pitch video which
mainly went up so that I could link it
to my patreon page so it's the first
thing that people see when they go on
there but unlike my last one which I
think I actually had set to unlisted I
decided I should make this one public so
I yeah but I wouldn't call that normal
content fireworks of the Daleks yeah it
is the season not having a great week
but this will be an awesome hour I am
sorry to hear it if it's not going great
for you yeah I hope uh hopefully do ok
for you for right now
I was kidding for reference sake you say
that but I don't know YouTube didn't
show me the new video so that's why I
asked I mean like like I said you didn't
miss much Oh with that one yellow lights
a bird blue lantern ravenclaw at your
services hi you know like other than
just being sick cuz you automatically
get red which I call BS on how do you
know your lightsaber color do you just
get to pick whatever or is there like
actually a method to that madness
anybody know 20 minutes late for a
meeting and I'm
and hey I was 20 minutes late for
meeting and hating myself earlier today
you're right on time
oh good to know how was the circus
circus was great I think this is the
third time I've taken my daughter to to
this particular circus so yeah it was a
good time it always is interesting water
bottle yeah I know right
sturdy I'm writing a sci-fi sitcom one
of the two main characters is bisexual I
reveal it in Episode three any tips on
how to handle it or what landmines to
avoid have a crop up casually in
conversation not even as the point just
like have them reference an X of either
gender like that don't be my go-to just
don't make a thing of it just establish
it I ask us sometimes YouTube would be
like I won't show you this because I
won't I had that problem with Alex
mayor's today yeah I wouldn't be shocked
if like it didn't give people a lot of
alerts because like not that not that I
expected the video to to do very well
but like when it wasn't posting high
numbers which I wouldn't expect a
patreon pitch to do I it I kind of
suspect like I bet you it doesn't show
up and a lot of people's feeds now have
you ever been to Gallifrey one before no
I will be going for the first time next
year so February so that'll be huh
that's a cross-country trip for me
that'll be interesting in Knights of the
Old Republic three of the lightsaber
colors had meaning outside the game so
not so much okay fair enough that's a
water bottle I thought it contained wine
oh no no no just water
and it may or may not actually be water
I'm not telling ah loving the widow's
peak wave match and I mean like that
that's just my natural hairline so
actually the the sort of wave effect is
I don't know within the last ten years
or so because that is hairline recession
right there that used to go straight
across and that is not new now I've had
it for a while and it hasn't gone any
further back that's where it's been for
a while now but ya didn't always have
that bit of uh smoothness at least I
only have to take a ring down the coast
for that one yeah caroling you're much
closer as far as going to Gallifrey one
goes dark red water dark red check your
eyesight my shirts dark red that not so
much he's too classy to drink wine out
of the bottle right right you do not
know me very well
[Laughter]
let's just get drunk in solidarity for
the Dark Phoenix movie are we still
mourning that I thought like people
gotten over it I've been to Gallifrey
one before I always wear a white
lemonade jacket with the doctors faces
and iconic objects ironed on there's a
large TARDIS on the back i I mean I
expect there's gonna be a TARDIS cuz
most cons I've gone to have a TARDIS
Vermont Comic Con had a TARDIS so like
if Gallifrey one didn't have a TARDIS
like somebody done messed up
if calibrate one didn't have one uh get
pissed off on camera it'll be funny oh
no not trying to hashtag definitely
water yes
if you see a girl wearing a jacket with
that description that's me I will try
and keep that in mind Rebecca I'm not
entirely sure what I'm like I figure
because I've got like proper accurate
cosplay for two doctors so those will
probably get featured at some point
other than that though I don't really
have a have a plan actually that's not
true I sort of have a plan because when
I do 13 it's gonna be not total accurate
I'm gonna like alter it slightly aside
from the fact that my hair isn't blonde
I'm not getting a wig but yeah that'll
be fun
Oh what is Gallifrey one Gallifrey one
is a Doctor Who convention that goes on
in LA and it's I was gonna say it's kind
of a big deal it kind of is but it's
also kind of forcibly small they have
refused to move it to a bigger venue
because they don't want it to lose its
flavor so it's one of those cons that
basically sells out within four days of
the tickets going live it's that it's
that kind of con I'm kind of doing that
with what I'm writing there's a scene
devoted to it but uh but none of the
characters don't make a big deal of it
the other main characters more surprised
that he didn't know until now okay I
mean like it always comes down to
execution but on paper yeah that could
work can you possibly do a ranking of
each story for every doctor that you
have seen the whole of their era ranked
every hard-nosed story from worse the
best and so on the problem is I can only
do that for new whoo I haven't seen
complete any of the classic dark suits
because the way I've been watching
classic who I have been jumping around I
have never gone I'm going to start at
the beginning of this doctor's run and
go all the way through I've just never
done that that's just like I think I
started to try to do that with the first
doctor I'm like I gotta shake this up
and then I like die jumping to a fourth
doctor
story after that or something but I mean
I'm not against the idea I'm a long way
off from being able to do it for anybody
other than modern era and I almost
wonder if especially with doing the
rewatch with overdue Doctor Who if it
would be kind of redundant given that at
the end of each series I'm ranking the
stories of that series I mean I suppose
I if people wanted I could still do like
all of tenants like top to bottom
I suppose I could I mean I've done a top
ten for him before so I could give it a
shot that would be - I want to keep it
under a half hour which would be tough
maybe let's go with maybe can you do a
northern the English accent like
Christopher Eccleston I refuse to
attempt to do an English accent or
really any accent especially while on
the live stream because I like to think
I'm decent in accents I'm pretty sure
I'm not and I don't really need to have
that confirmed by other people that I'm
actually kind of crap at it can I call
you that uh no you may not
thank you for asking but no no you may
not
let's talk Sandman on Netflix I am NOT
going to say too much about that because
I'm gonna actually after this live
stream is over I'm gonna shoot a video
on it um long story short I feel better
about it than I did when the news first
drop now I have I haven't tracked down
exactly what Gore's involvement is but
it's not as big as initially reported
because it was initially reported that
like he was writing the scripts but he's
not Gaiman and a British TV writer whose
work I don't really know are are working
the scripts right now at
this point or at least that's the that's
the plan
I don't think production works actually
started on this it's just like the deals
been done
I think Goyer still involved somehow he
may only be producing which is about as
much as I would want him involved I
don't have a particularly high opinion
of David Goyer as a as a writer but I'll
have more complete thoughts and those
will go out Friday
thank you very much Devon much
appreciated please don't try to copy my
accent well I don't know what your
accent is but alright so I suppose
you're you're from the north did you see
the picture of The Witcher TV series has
there been a new one
I remember the the one that came out
like months ago of Henry Cavill is a
Cavalier cavil I can't remember but
Henry Cavill like done up in the outfit
never ones like it looks like cosplay
like I remember that months ago so if
new pictures have come out I haven't
seen them I'm not exceptionally invested
in the idea of a Witcher TV series I
mean I'll check it out if I can see it
but like I've never read the books I've
never played the games it's you know it
struck me as a fairly standard dark you
know high fantasy story and I'm sure
it's fine for that but you know it needs
to really be bringing something to the
table if that's what it's going for it
doesn't have hang you'll live in
California I do not I was however born
in California don't ask me what it was
like though we moved before I was one so
loved the glasses I really I really do
like these guys it's actually coming out
of the circus somebody complimented
these which was really cool always heard
it as Cavill I've heard both so I don't
know
have you watched any of Jessica Jones
season three um I've seen one episode of
Jessica Jones season 3 which was fine
like the thing is even if it's better
than season 2 which I for how I felt
about season 2 is not that high bar to
clear I already think it can't possibly
do much more than let me down because
that first season of Jessica Jones
despite having a couple of filler
episodes simply because it didn't need
13 but in terms of focus in terms of
theming in terms of having a solid
central conceit that first season is so
tight and the the second season just
wasn't and this season even though it
feels a bit more focused than season two
still feels like it's falling under the
same traps and actually I'll just say
this quickly
it had the latter seasons of Jessica
Jones have the same fundamental problem
that I had with the second season of
stranger things which is that the first
season is built around a core central
concept so in the case of Jessica Jones
it's her damage from killgrave and in
the case of stranger things it's missing
kit and everything else every character
every subplot everything circles around
that central concept in both cases when
they came to the second season what they
ended up doing was just taking all the
characters who had been in the first one
who were there because their stories
circled that central concept and kept
the rare around and give them sub
stories and subplots and their own
things because they were in the last one
but there is no longer that central core
idea that brings everyone together
they're scattered to the winds and we're
just following them because they were
there last time like I don't go in with
Jessica Jones I don't know why Hogarth
is still around
I like Carrie and moss I like her in
this part but everything was so
centrally focused in the first season of
Jessica Jones I can't help but view
every subsequent season through the lens
of why is that here how is that
contributing and a lot of it doesn't
it's just there
and the first season didn't have stuff
that was just there so that weapons rack
you got on the side you are they real or
web liquor or replica weapons I think
the only stuff up here that is actually
usable are the sigh everything else is
you you you would not actually want to
swing that hang on the Cutlass is
probably the best quality and would have
the best shot at being viable as a
legitimate weapon but the rest that's up
here the katanas the the broadsword the
the axe definitely the Claymore that
things kind of a piece of crap yeah
that's that stuff's just you know just
for show and I don't know how to
properly use any of it let me also point
that out what I'll uh see speaking uh
what to call you I like calling you the
wild counsel
hahaha I like that replica weapons now
edge see I'm currently wearing the same
glasses but I added rhinestones to my
new hashtag burlesque like yes that's a
burly detail I love it maybe the water
is too strong possibly where's your new
beau hanging out my new beau is over in
the corner it's not it's not strong
currently I mean I need to get a leather
grip for it so I can use it properly
I made a who tuber wiki if I were to
link it in the comments of one of your
videos would it get marked as spam um
initially yes but I review those so I
clear that to go up if you wanted to
delenn
to it have you ever tried stage or
reenactment combat asking because of the
weapons I've done a bit of stage combat
because I I took theater when I was in
college it was well it was my minor
should have been my major if it had been
I might have actually finished but um so
yeah I've done a bit of stage combat not
um weapons the only weapon that I have
any degree of training whatsoever is a
bo staff which I have one of those over
actually over in the corner with my long
bow but I never I never got to do a lot
of weapons stage combat but I know I
know a fair amount of hand-to-hand stage
Thomas stage combat you know how to how
to safely choke do a slap how to how to
fall correctly how to throw somebody oh
the the head slam that's my that's my
favorite one to do obviously with a
partner who knows what they're doing you
know you grab the hair into oh okay yes
alright I don't know what happened there
sorry about that
minor hiccup
wait if you were born in California
how are you out the hair before you were
born is that like a doctor who think not
what I said I said I left California
before I turned one that's what I said
you know that there is a there's a
period of time between when you're born
when you turn one just don't remember it
what part of you from I I was I was born
in Mendocino not Mendocino County like
Mendocino look technically up the road
the Fort Bragg hospital but that's where
my mother was living was was Mendocino
which I've gone back to see and it is it
is Mendocino California is almost
offensively beautiful like it it's it's
the kind of beautiful thing that kind of
annoys you what the hell this should be
in a painting I shouldn't be able to
walk down this cuz it is it is a town
built on cliffs directly into the ocean
it's gorgeous
forgot about the live stream I'm about
to make a bagel a bagel not a muffin
really how do you come up with
consistently good cold opens are they
consistently good haha news to me um I
don't know 99 times out of 100 I don't
plan them ahead of time I just sit down
I start the record I'll do my pose for
whatever I'm gonna send a Joel to use
for the thumbnail and then I like I'll
sit for ten to thirty seconds and go
with whatever is the first idea that
comes in my head that I don't hate about
Dark Crystal age of resistance will you
be watching oh heck yeah absolutely I
will be you look really nice today I
look sweaty today that's why the hair is
pulled back I am I like as soon as this
is done I'm taking a shower
I am I'm a sweaty mess I spent two hours
under a big top-10 watching watching a
circus with my kids so that which which
if you live in New England Siri
seriously
they just started their tour if you have
not seen this it's awesome
and if you're one of those peoples like
Oh circus Cruelty to Animals there's no
animals
it's just performers and actually aside
from the ringmaster they're all kids
they like go to a camp to learn how to
do this stuff and it's it's clowns and
it's tumbling and it's acrobatics and
it's aerial and the aerial stuff's
amazing so if you live in Vermont New
Hampshire Maine Massachusetts I think
they do one location in Connecticut
their tour in this summer
women over du/dr who review gets up to
episodes you've already reviewed will
yury review them or stop the series um I
actually have thought about that because
I'm a couple years off from actually
getting there I think I might just keep
going and rewrite rebrand it as Doctor
Who take to review since there will
already be a previous review up for
those we'll see we'll see how I feel
when I get there but that's sort of the
option I'm keeping in my back pocket I'm
not gonna promise that but that's sort
of that's kind of where my head's at a
little bit can you do a good British
accent I probably not like if I were to
try and do a British accent I it would
probably be a wandering British accent
that's sort of my main issue with
accents it's not that I do them badly I
have a hard time holding on to them like
if I try and do because like I'll do
voices and accents to amuse my kid so
like if I start out doing Scottish I've
had that wander over into Russian on me
or I'll have like a British accent go
posh and then like get more
working-class
as I go so like I can't I can't I don't
know axes well enough to hold it
consistently it's my problem
would you do a Buffy episode by episode
reviews probably not um
I think like for two reasons one is to
be completely blunt about it the times
that I've done Buffy material it's not
some of the better if you better viewed
material on the channel it also doesn't
help that passion of the nerd is kind of
doing the definitive Buffy episode by
episode review and like it's one of
those cases where it's it's the same
reason that I don't see myself ever
doing a deep dive into a movie that's
been covered by Dan Olsen or Lindsey
Ellis or Patrick Williams cuz they're
all just too good at that and I kind of
feel the same way about how passionate
the nerd talks about Buffy he's so good
at it makes me go I have no contribution
bagel on the toaster I'll keep you
posted on his whereabouts for the next
15 minutes good we were we were
desperately in need of updates on that
bagel I'm a thing oh hello there looks
like Mark Hamill will be voicing a
character in Dark Crystal called the
doctor hmm interesting
why do you think the United Federation
of Planets isn't a utopia anymore um
Lauren okay so this is a Star Trek
question basically because the only
person who ever wanted it to be a utopia
is Gene Roddenberry and he's been dead
long enough that they just don't hold to
that anymore
and I like I'm not just saying that
facetiously that was a big like butting
of heads at the at the writing stage for
Star Trek The Next Generation
it was Roddenberry's edict that the
federation was good and that the
Federation officers all got along and
that drove the writers crazy because it
eliminated whole swathes of ways that
you would know
we develop drama you know between
characters and some I might even argue
that it forced them to find other ways
to do it rather than resulting to cheap
melodrama but at the same time it drove
writers crazy not being able to have the
characters butt heads for more than like
a one-off episode and like not have
overcoming conflict between each other
be an ongoing thing so yeah like nobody
other than Roddenberry wanted it to be a
utopia what video would you say you're
most proud of
ooh I I don't know cuz anybody I there's
I don't think at least not off the top
my head there's nothing up I don't think
that I'm embarrassed by but pretty much
even the stuff that I really like that
I'm really proud of um there's still be
wanted to nitpicky things that'll bug me
it's like Oh why'd you say like that bit
or like oh you should have added that
and I I don't know um I honestly don't
know cyberpunk 2077 excited for it or
don't care well I don't have a current
gen system and I don't have a PC that
can run modern video games so by default
I kind of don't care I'm not gonna play
it uh you can go with utopia idea but
also a conflict ds9 for example see I
never got heavily into ds9 but I I think
Roddenberry had passed by the time ds9
started so he didn't really have his
fingers in that one or if he or if he
hadn't already he did soon after it
started
have you seen any Australian kids shows
from back in the day like girl from the
future around the twist
no funnily enough Northeast US doesn't
get a lot of Australian
shows piped in don't know why can't
imagine
I enjoyed Voyager I enjoy Kate Mulgrew
as Janeway I'm like the the start
there's no Star Trek series I've seen
every episode of the one that I've seen
the most of is next generation the bits
of Voyager I've seen are ok she's one of
the better elements some of the
supporting cast in Voyager is bland and
wooden and enterprise I couldn't get
into it all I think I've seen two
episodes of enterprise I just couldn't d
s9 like I've only ever caught bits and
pieces I realized early I was like oh
this is one of those things that's gonna
have ongoing story and like I when it
was airing I didn't have TV in my home
like incoming TV so like I didn't have
the opportunity to watch a week over
week so I'd like I didn't really have
the chance to keep up well but keep up
with it or even really get into it
properly pretty sure if I tried it now
I'd like it but like you know I don't
have the time
I forgot that America is so insular when
it comes to entertainment I mean like we
are but like entertainment is also one
of those areas where America like we're
really huge on exporting everything as
far as that goes
Enterprise was okay it just didn't feel
like Star Trek for some reason well for
starters the opening had lyrics the
opening theme had lyrics what the hell
was that
that him that threw me off immediately
wait is this your bedroom is it huh look
at that
bagel is officially buttered oh thanks I
was starting to worry should call a
doctor who reviewed DejaVu
ooh that's a mouthful have you ever
watched The Walking Dead or is it not
your type of thing I did the first
season of The Walking Dead and I just
didn't stick with it after that not
because it was bad but because I've seen
enough zombie media that I didn't feel
like it was bringing anything to the
table that I haven't seen before and you
know having talked with people who stuck
with it after that I'm actually quite
glad I bowed out after the first season
but like it wasn't bad it just didn't do
nothing about it felt new to me I feel
like most of people who really got into
the Walking Dead were people who didn't
who hadn't seen a ton of zombie stuff
because it's pretty run-of-the-mill
at that first season at least at the end
of the day maybe maybe it's someone
else's bedroom yes we've noticed America
is big on exporting their media like the
UK and the 60s
are like in the UK like 60 to 70 percent
of our TV is American well I mean part
of that also just has to do with the
fact that you you know you've got to
fill time and you know there's only so
many channels producing content in the
UK and if you've got more channels and
more hours in the day then you've got
new content you can buy it from American
fill it in do you butter your pay hole
right side up or upside down oh god do
not start a butter battle in my comment
section butter battle book anybody else
I feel like nobody read that dr. Seuss I
love that book it was one of my
favorites I feel like nobody read that
one
Breaking Bad was pretty good I don't
know if you saw that one Breaking Bad
was good it was good um okay Lucy I
can't check my patreon in the middle of
the of the livestream
I'd have to like get into something sign
out like I will check it as soon as the
live streams over all right
I remember bladder battle Oh God oh good
good
awesome people do remember other people
read it
yay milk or cereal first what this is
not the first time I've been asked that
question
who puts milk in first like what why
what who when I feel like that that's
something you put in a TV show or a
movie as a character trait to
immediately mark out somebody is weird
not that I'm saying that like you're a
weird freak if you do do that I'm just
like well I I don't get it and
recommendations for good werewolf media
besides the classics I'm running dry
here there is not a lot of good werewolf
stuff out there Dog Soldiers if you
haven't seen it check that one out
it's fun it's it's not exceptionally
serious but it's fun does your daughter
know what being gender-fluid is if you
were to ask her it in those words
probably not
um I mean she knows what I'm like so she
has an understanding just probably not
um the terminology cuz it's not like I
sat down to talk with her about labels
so yeah I think she does understand just
not not in those terms Oh
other good where will they haven't seen
it yeah yeah especially the first one
you need to be willing to roll with some
wonky practical effects cuz it's low
budget but the gingersnaps trouble
gee very good and actually the second -
really underappreciated those are quite
good for werewolf stuff you put soda in
first who puts milk in first oh god what
has been unleashed in the Japs oh no
it's about to start his 10th season it's
up there being my favorite shows of all
time with Doctor Who oh that's great
fantastic for you I don't really want to
go back and watch it um you know based
off what I've heard did you hear about
office leaving Netflix um I mean I did I
never got into the office seemed fine
not really for me i sir drink first
unless it's a fancy ice cube in which
case he has showed off in the glass
before you pour something over it drink
first then ice would you do a ranking of
Batman movies if not what's your
favorite here's my problem with that cuz
I actually did have the idea and I don't
know if I'll do it I'm probably gonna
regret saying it out loud I did have the
idea of ranking every Batman movie
including the animated ones so basically
anything that's feature-length that
features Batman as the primary character
so that would be my way of avoiding
movies where he simply appears like say
Suicide Squad or Justice League where
he's just part of the team I the thing
is there's only a handful of movies that
I'd have to see that I haven't yet in
order to do that if you're gonna
restrict me to live-action
it's probably the Dark Knight still I
know it's become like the cool thing to
say that that movies overrated it's
really not um I do really have a soft
spot for the 89 Batman no where are the
Harry Potter Harry Potter videos you
promised traveling if I promised and
well first of all I don't pay it
promised anything yeah I'm trying to
think if I've mentioned anything other
than sorting other franchises into
Hogwarts houses and possibly a second
video on sex ed at Hogwarts and I'm
still like percolating on those so they
haven't gone away I just it's it's not
easy to budget my time in my schedule to
get to everything you know stuff takes
time folks again if I promise something
other than those you may need to remind
me cuz if I didn't write it down it may
be gone into the ether 89 Batman is good
but I will admit I'm more partial to the
Nolan Batman movies I mean I would I
would rate the Batman 89 absolutely over
Dark Knight Rises probably over Batman
Begins also are you ever gonna do a
video ranking the x-men movies yes I
need to see Dark Phoenix before I can do
that
and because I missed it locally I'm
gonna have to wait till it's available
digitally so I'm a little ways off on
that Kevin Conroy second only dad I'm
west for me is the best Batman and Mark
Hamill is the best Joker I mean that's
solid the anime Joker's the true Joker
for me I'm not like one of the nice
things about Batman and Batman's rogues
gallery and the Joker in particular
that these characters have been around
long enough and reinterpreted enough
times that you don't necessarily get a
quote-unquote truer interpretation
because you can simply choose to
emphasize different elements of the
characters and it's still accurate like
the Heath Ledger's agent of chaos is no
less accurate a joker than Jack
Nicholson's insane mob boss both are
valid it's just a shift in what elements
you're gonna bring in cuz again
characters been around for so long and
done in so many ways you get a lot of
options what was nice about Mark Hamill
because he got to play the characters so
many times he got to explore way more of
all the options at sort of the
smorgasbord then a lot of other actors
got to do basically got to pick one
thing and then dig into that so if you
were gonna say there's a definitive
interpretation of Joker that would be
the closest that said not all of the
times he's played the Joker have been
great I'm looking at you The Killing
Joke but I am more inclined to blame the
script just because I don't like Brian
Azzarello
and I'll take a chance to dunk on the
man and possibly the direction with
classic who I'm currently going in
chronological order power to you then
it's stronger than I am I don't see the
fun in picking and choose random stories
to be honest um for me I just I love the
variety I mean that's what attracted me
to Doctor Who in the first place the
fact that it can go anywhere and do
anything and when taking in classic who
getting able to jump between stories
between eras between doctors just gives
me even more of that feel I'm not stuck
in one particular way of thinking about
how the doctor is being handled for an
extended period like I would be if I
went chronological again that's just a
matter of preference though I'm not
saying what I'm doing is better I'm just
explaining why it works for me a DD
there is your short answer I have a TD
so I like to jump around wham bam what
is going on
have you watched Kung Fu Hustle I love
kung fu hustle holy cow that movie's
great so good and it was really good cuz
I'd seen Shaolin Soccer which was a
movie that was okay but I wanted to like
more than I did and then Kung Fu Hustle
came out I'm like this is everything
that worked from Shaolin Soccer none of
the stuff that didn't work and it's all
been refined to this glorious bit of
insanity if you've never seen kung fu
hustle and you don't mind subtitles you
need to check it out it is nuts and the
best kind of nuts in your opinion what
you what should you avoid when writing
comedy um see that like that's that is a
tough thing to answer because honestly I
can't offer you any much more than just
the golden rules of comedy don't punch
down is is a big one that I wish more
people would obey it seems to have
become edgy to ignore that rule but you
know other than that my personal
preference is to avoid you being overly
topical but that's only because it dates
the material but if depending on what
you're doing
maybe the material is dated to a
specific time so that's just my
preference comedy is comedy really can
be a science sometimes different kinds
of comedy function different ways but it
is it's so specific and it's so tight
and it can be a difference of
millimeters in terms of whether a joke
works or not I mean the main thing about
the actual delivery though the writing
is one thing comedy almost
always comes down to delivery that's why
I think it's it's harder to be funny in
print than it is on stage because such a
big component of comedy is timing and
when something is in print you cannot
control the pace that somebody read
something so timing doesn't enter into
it as much I must go now I will thank
you for stopping in Dakota much
appreciate it
ad D solidarity haha Cheers
Kung Fu Hustle is getting a sequel is
Stephen Chow doing it or somebody else
doing it that's my one and only question
why is this channel on IMDB because web
series can get listed on IMDB why
wouldn't it be
have you considered watching Chernobyl
well I don't HBO after end of Game of
Thrones so not really sometimes I find
that I write better comedy when I
haven't set out to write comedy seems to
happen on its own it is a I think I was
gonna say it's not just comedy though I
think in general if you sit down trying
to evoke a specific emotional response
like that's your goal I think it becomes
immediately harder like you sit down and
go
today I will be funny today I will be
romantic today I will be sad and tragic
it's gonna be a slog and a grind I my my
own personal Golden Rule for writing if
it's a narrative or if we're talking
narrative and again take this with a
huge grain of salt I've finished a novel
that I've been shopping around for
friggin ever no one's bid on it I may
suck at this but anyways my own golden
rule when writing narrative is the story
is king everything is story so when you
go in you're first and foremost story
doing priority should be tell
a good story and weaving that story well
where so many people I think stumble and
where you can often end up with
something really pretentious is if you
come in with a goal that is not about
the story a goal that's about I want to
make people feel this no come up with a
story work the story work the characters
and as you work that figure out what
emotions you can evoke through the story
you're telling as opposed to trying to
orchestrate events in the story in order
to elicit a specific emotion that's when
it comes across as manipulative and
people reject it I have a very important
questions do you believe in flying
muffins sure today why not
or uh actually let's let's say if
there's a steady paycheck in it I
believe anything you say
is it weird or wrong that I'm glad Iain
M banks and Terry Pratchett are dead
because that means neither author can
say anything that will disappoint me um
wrong no a little morbid maybe but I
mean that's that's a reality sometimes
like you there's a reason that there's
that old phrase never meet your heroes
because you can build up someone in your
mind and then when you meet them or hear
things that they've said or done
ultimately they're just human and not to
get overly cynical but humans let you
down
that's kind it's kind of what we do as a
species we're really good at it both
collectively and individually or
extremely good at that so you know there
is I think sambal is some validity to
feeling like oh well at least this
person being
dad means they can't disappoint me in
some way so like is that a little morbid
not wrong the final problem is a good
example of what not to do still remember
that mess well are you talking about
like the actual original Sherlock Holmes
story or the last episode of the BBC
show Sherlock would you consider a
character being comically stupid to be
punching down the head comically stupid
is tough for a couple of reasons the the
first is that comically stupid
characters have a tendency to just be
annoying always be careful if you are
constructing a character that is
annoying to the other characters because
odds are there will also be annoying to
the audience and as far as comically
stupid goes I think word you need to be
careful how other characters treat and
react to them so if the primary
interaction is other characters pointing
out how stupid this character is yeah
that's kind of punching down kind of let
myself forget a lot of the final problem
you're better off that way that thing
was such a mess
have you seen Good Omens yet I have a
review up quick okay question about
whether or not I've seen something I
already reviewed everybody drink did you
watch dark on Netflix I don't even know
what that is
what's comically stupid done right re
not annoying um I would say you could
take a look at the early seasons of Red
Dwarf Lister
kind of comic Lisa here's okay here's
the thing if you're doing comic estupid
you can't have them be stupid across the
board you can have them be lacking in
knowledge or experience where they don't
have the foundation to understand what
the heck is going on but you know
they're not it's not that they're unable
to process information so like you you
need to figure out exactly how are they
stupid so think of it as the inverse of
street smart versus book smart are they
book stupid or are they street stupid
cuz if you do all of it just like if you
have a character that is smart in every
possible way that's boring if you have a
character that's stupid in every
possible way I'm not going to say it's
impossible to work somebody will
probably put an example of the time it's
work in the chat but like that's a hard
needle to thread
what's your unpublished novel about I
wrote a fantasy novel that is God trying
to think of there's a short version of
this pitch which is probably part of my
problem it is a it is a Victorian level
technology for humans clashing with a
world of fairies Nutt and when I say
clashing I don't mean outright like or
anything but like that's the tension in
the world and and there's a little
there's a little bit of x-men kind of a
feel to it because it deals with people
who exhibit innate you know magical
abilities that they can barely control
which makes them inherently dangerous
and greatly feared and also sort of not
of either world they are feared amongst
humans but humans are not going to be
welcome among the more magical worlds of
the forest so it follows a character I
who has that condition
and there are a few others like that so
bright but steampunk well no cuz it's
not modern day setting it's you know
it's an original world with its own
history and and all of that stuff
did you see the Charlie's Angel trailer
I did not I missed that
Jason from the good places yeah Jason
Jason is a good example of comically
stupid but it's worth pointing out he
has a certain degree of emotional
intelligence like he doesn't know
anything and he can't process
information very well but he can get a
read on people in terms of like good
good dude bad dude like he has a certain
degree of emotional intelligence if
nothing else so he's not completely
devoid um and also he's got a really
good heart he wants to do well he wants
to do right he just has a very poor
consumption of what that even is like
it's it yeah the good place is amazing
probably is understood more succinctly
if she said steampunk London conflicting
with high fantasy yeah I mean like I
said I have I haven't like I haven't
actually tried to pitch the thing and
over a year so like my pitch on it is
rusty yeah I don't I don't know what I'm
gonna do with that thing I'll do
something with eventually because it's
it's done basically I mean a neat Nathan
editor need to needs a few more beta
readers and he's a polish but it's
basically done and I'm almost done like
another another book in the same world
so like I want to do something with the
dang stuff I've sunk enough time into
them now I'm worried I'm doing teenage
Jason
I mean look you're gonna have your
influences especially like not not to
sound like a patronizing jackass except
I probably am a bit of a patronizing
jackass
so like TV TV
said I I know how young you are you're
allowed to steal stuff like knots of a
little anything that you're working on
but pretty much anything you're writing
now at this point your life as a
teenager is practice is to get good at
the act of writing so that you can
refine just the process of doing it it's
okay to have to be heavily influenced by
other stuff if you have a level of
awareness of it that helps don't rip off
intentionally
but it's okay to borrow because you need
to put something on paper the biggest
mistake that most creative people have
is they leave it up in their heads and
they never actually get it out because
they're too busy thinking about it
they're too busy thinking about oh but
it's not original enough it's like this
this characters like that this character
speaks like this person from that movie
just write it whatever it is whatever it
is whatever it sounds like even if it's
junk
write it down cuz once you write it down
you can rework it you can revise it
people think they can revise in their
heads and like suddenly their first
draft is this magical you're glowing
scroll from the gods oh and it won't
even need an editor that doesn't happen
it's always it is write it down and
revise it revise it revise it it takes
forever it's a slog but you can't revise
what you don't have on paper
did you see the CGI series dinosaurs
with Earl Sinclair no that does not ring
a bell
thank you for answering my email but the
way it was nice to hear back from that
yeah I'm trying to catch up on emails I
had a few that was several weeks old
that I meant to respond to how do you
keep your focus when writing you just
asked a person with a DD how do you keep
focus
[Music]
catch a wave sometimes is is what you
need to do you know sir come on
okay
are we
as working about that I I can't even
remember what I was talking about oh
yeah how to stay focused when writing
like uh trying to trying to stay focused
when writing is just sometimes you know
you just got to sit down and force
yourself to just start to write and then
if you're lucky you'll you know you'll
push through but the other thing is like
if you feel inspiration frigging drop
whatever else you're doing and sit down
and write like do not let that stuff
slip you by did you know that EMM Banks
was dead you refer to him in present
tense I did not realize that when I shot
the review I did not realize that till
after I did know when the book was
written so once I found out I wasn't
hugely surprised by that but no III
didn't know that when I shot the review
you didn't sound too patronizing you
actually had some pretty good advice so
thanks sweet love it see love dinosaurs
have it on DVD
maybe solar flavors are doing the
buffering oh geez I remember when I
thought my first draft was flawless I
look back on it wonder how the hell I
did that I'm probably gonna do the same
thing with my current draft I mean yeah
I mean that's the other thing you need
to realize is the the first hurdle to
overcome is finishing a first draft is
getting it down on paper and having a
complete story that is probably flawed
as hell but you have something that is
the first hurdle the second hurdle is
knowing when to stop revising because at
a certain point you're not making it
better
you're just tinkering endlessly which is
a trap you can fall into
oh why is this telling me very bad
connection Oh God's sake well it's been
about an hour I might close it up soon
folks cuz this this thing is really
determined to cop out on me I don't know
if my internet has slowed down or what
the advice about putting things on paper
is one of the best bits of writing
advice ever Hey look at that you're
coming in fine it just it keeps giving
me a warning it's dropped twice already
so I don't even know what to make of it
if you were only allowed to choose one
piece of literature to read for the rest
of your life and no other what would you
choose um probably the last unicorn
would you you've only seen the movie you
haven't read the book you are missing
out does it literally have to be on
paper
no it's figure of speech it can be on a
computer screen I type when I write oh
you was so so late to the live stream
you need to make up time you cheeky
bugger
how much of a difference would you say
there is between script writing and book
writing um in terms of how you go about
telling your story not a huge amount but
there's certainly a lot of difference in
what you spend your time writing because
the thing is even though I've written a
novel um my brain thinks in terms of
dialogue scenes because most of the
entertainment I take in is TV and movies
I read books but not nearly as much as I
take in this other stuff so in my head
when I'm first outlining something I
tend to think of it in terms of dialogue
scenes
and it was funny when I first sat down
to actually write the book the one
that's not published because I'd been
thinking about it for years and part of
the reason I hadn't sat down to do it
was I was convinced that I only had at
most three chapters of material because
in my head the way the story went was
okay and then these characters have this
conversation and then you know some
stuff happens and then these characters
have this bit of dialogue and I'd like
written out some of the dialogues like
and then some stuff happens not
realizing that thee and then some stuff
happens is pages and pages and pages of
description and action and motivations
and and you know getting to know the
characters through things other than
dialogue so it's since like a lot of my
early writing in like high school and
whatever was things like short plays I
was I was thinking so much in terms of
dialogue it until I sat down to do it it
didn't occur to me how much other stuff
there is to write right whereas if you
write a screenplay or stage play pretty
much all you write is the dialogue and
very specific important physical action
because generally it's gonna be left to
the director to decide how best to have
this play out than the actors and I need
its best leave that freedom I think does
this book have a title um it has a
working title I haven't I haven't
bothered to check lately cuz like when I
came up with it years ago now I couldn't
find a notable book that used the title
but at the same time like it I feel like
it's generic so I kind of want to come
up with something else
I have the same experience of my old
YouTube videos I don't know what the
hell I was thinking and some of them and
some of those are less than a year old
and there's um there's something I
forget the first time I've heard this
but I've heard it repeated a few times
since which is that basically every
artists artists hate everything they did
they did more than five years ago and I
think that there's a fair amount of
accuracy in that so you haven't gotten
into the office how did you get to work
all this time I love you people years
skirting gendered - I have like debated
working on a kind of follow-up to that
you focusing basically more of my
personal life you know navigating
relationships and parenting and things
like that I don't know if what I have to
say that wasn't already said in skirting
gender is enough to warrant another book
I don't know I haven't even sat down to
try and do that
I've heard that as you are your greatest
critic well I would actually say you
should be your greatest critic because
if you're not your greatest critic that
usually means you think you're amazing
and that's a that's a whole other
different thing to deal with
skirting gender to electric bull ooh oh
dear oh dear oh dear how do you stay on
one idea ha ha ha how do I stay on one
idea I have finished novel a 3/4
finished novel a narrative podcast
sketched out I have a play that I've
written I have a screenplay that I've
written
I have more short stories than I can
count and I have always jumped between
projects I really I really forced myself
to sit down and focus on skirting gender
and and the novel for different reasons
the first being with the novel I wanted
to have a finished draft well in my mind
I wanted it published so that when my
daughter was old enough that she was an
appropriate age to read it that she
could and I mean I suppose she'd still
be a little young for it so maybe it's
not too late for that but I really
wanted it in a finished state so that
was what forced that's what I kicked
myself in the butt with for that
and with skirting gender I realized that
if I didn't do something soon because I
was I was starting to move away from
updating the veer Wilde channel
regularly and I was focusing with sort
of that end of my life more on burlesque
performance I was realizing that
whatever sort of cache of reputation of
clout that I had to talk about that you
know whatever minimal amount being on on
YouTube and having written that one
cracked article that day quite well
gave me was going to expire soon so that
was a big
of what kicked me in the butt to finish
skirting gender was just fearing that if
there was a window for that project that
it was closing on me
could you get skirting gendered to be an
audiobook look I would have one of two
hurdles to overcome with trying to do
skirting gender as an audiobook which I
would actually like to do the first is
either I would have to shell out to hire
someone to read it I'd actually kind of
like to read it myself
but if I do that I'm going to have to
probably get better recording setup than
I have I'm gonna have to find the time
to do that which like that's a lot of
time and multiple takes also realize so
like if the if me reading the book ends
up being let's be conservative and say
nine hours that's finished product it's
gonna take minimum minimum triple that
to you know in terms of recording time
and then I need to hire a sound engineer
to put it together into something
halfway decent cuz I don't know how to
do that so yeah I I like the idea of
having skirting gender as a as an
audiobook I would like to do that but
like the logistics of it are impractical
you know for her there are lots of
things that I would really really like
to do but the number of them that I can
work on it all is limited and some of
them I just I feel like I can't even
begin to tackle as long as I'm still
working a 40-hour a week day job you
know
so how would you describe the movie
Fantasia gorgeous yeah I mean other than
that I think you know the film describes
itself pretty well in the opening it is
it is a visualization of music in
various wonderful ways I really do like
Fantasia quite a bit actually
you dori yourself why not hire someone
well because skirting gender is my story
so like if I ever published the novel
and if that ever had an audiobook I'd
hire someone to do that someone who like
didn't do the you know give different
voice to different characters like I'd
hire someone to do that but skirting
gender that's my story that's me I would
prefer to tell that I'm a little
possessive what's your favorite Saturday
morning cartoon as a kid I'm not sure
what it was at the time in hindsight
it's the Real Ghostbusters cuz that one
has held up the best of the ones that I
was into when I was I was young just
focus on fixing your TARDIS priorities
yeah but you just get the TARDIS working
I I'd have enough time for everything
and it would be amazing did you watch
the new Lindsay Ellis video on Game of
Thrones I did I see her videos pretty
soon after they premiere she's really
good it's your words though needs to be
your voice at that right no no black
cover it's not that it's my words
it's that skirting gender that book is
my story about my life and the things
I've learned about myself it's not about
the words it's not about having written
the words it's about the fact that the
story those words are telling is mine me
not like I invented it like I freaking
lived it that's what makes it my story
and that's why I would feel
very frankly uncomfortable hearing
someone else tell it
I've been binging Lindsay Ellis videos
after you mentioned her on a live stream
she's awesome she really is she's really
pretty good at what she does I read a
powerful book on black British culture
it was read by the author who was not a
trained audiobook reader and the book
was so much more powerful because she
read it I feel like in general if it is
a narrative if it's fictional author
reading their own work probably a bad
idea because most authors aren't voice
actors and probably not gonna do it
particularly well there are exceptions
but by and large leave it to somebody
else if it's autobiographical in any way
I would rather hear the author's voice
that's me
heman Shira gobots transformers GI Joe
Dragon Ball Z Sailor Moon etc oh boy
yeah see when I was so when I was young
the the big Saturday morning cartoons
were he-man transformers which I didn't
watch GI Joe which I didn't watch
Thundercats Real Ghostbusters Ninja
Turtles would come on but that was on
the tail end of me watching Saturday
morning cartoons I did really dig them
though would you say there's a
difference between in a nerd and a geek
if so what is it well yeah the nerd is
the academic form of the geek the nerd
is the one who needs to like needs to
needs to break it apart turn it into
equation the nerd is book-smart the geek
is just obsessive and is and just dives
into it because they're doing that
instead of doing something productive
that sounded really dismissive but like
I I'm very lucky that I can have my
rewatching Doctor Who for the who knows
how many times the result in videos that
I get to share with people but it might
in my mind being a nerd requires a
certain there's a certain bar of
intellectual standing anybody can be a
geek anybody is a geek everybody's a
geek about something like sports fans
are our geeks
you know carb car people car nuts
they're geeks their automotive geeks I
being a geek is just a really obsessive
level interest in something fairly
specific
that's geeking out over a thing now if
you're asking like for a definition of
geek media that sort of become a weird
corporatized
thing so that's that's a little bit more
cynical to define silverhawks
oh god I forget about Silverhawks
given the title and can time I'll sign
off now yeah I should as well so I have
wine running to the kitchen yes that is
an emergency
did you ever see the movie Little Ashes
from 2008 Robert Pattinson as dolly very
interesting themes I didn't I did hear
he played that but most of what Robert
Pattinson has been up to just not my
kind of movie why do people think geeks
who like sports and cars are considered
normal while geeks who like comic books
and anime are considered unacceptable I
don't know I don't know why some
interests are more accepted than others
so like because I will stand by the fact
that you know people obsessed with
superheroes are not decidedly different
from people obsessed with a sports team
it's the same instinct it's just
directed at something else and yeah as
you said one is considered more normal
one is or at least until recently was
considered weird uh-huh I'm a weird
person I'm not gonna judge don't end
this dream please I need dude dude I
gotta take a shower I'm sweaty I'm gross
I gotta wash my hair I gotta shoot a
video it's it's quarter past 10:00 at
night where I am I I do need to stop do
you want any of that Star Wars Girls
video I have not heard of that channel
so no not at present so yeah I am gonna
wrap it up everybody thank you for
tuning in for listening this was a very
unstructured even by my standards but if
you're in the US over you have a great
4th of July if you're not and
have to work that day I hope it is a
decent day for you regardless so thanks
for tuning in thanks for sharing your
time with me and your beautiful you are
valid you are loved your the council and
I just run the meetings with water